c'est passé beaucoup de choses
à 6 mois il y a six mois nous
rencontrions hola pour la deuxième fois
elle est sa fille Anastasia sont arrivés
au Québec en avril dernier fuyant la
guerre en Ukraine comme des milliers
d'autres
Anastasia parlait à peine anglais et là
aujourd'hui quitté le Québec pour un
emploi en Ontario sa mère ola est restée
elle est capable de nous accorder une
courte entrevue en français pour moi
c'est difficile à peindre le français et
je travaille beaucoup et force je
travaille de la maison
avec ma famille
québécois sa famille québécoise si
Anne-Marie et son mari qui l'accueille
chez eux depuis presque un an des fois
elle m'appelle maman quand j'achète un
peu comme une mère poule mais je pense
ça m'a un nouveau l'intégration au
niveau de sa
son apprentissage du français moi je
pense toujours que ça va très très bien
depuis son arrivée au Canada Allah
consacré toutes ces journées à apprendre
le français récemment elle s'est trouvée
un emploi celle qui dans une autre vie
était professeure d'université en
Ukraine et désormais assistante dans une
garderie puis il y a des gens qui l'ont
appelé une présélection au téléphone
puis c'est sûr qu'il y avait quelques
mots qu'elle savait pas donc elle me
passait le téléphone après que le dame a
dit mais elle sait que c'est très bien
en français
bravo
je trouve une bonne travail
et apprendre le prendre le français
en travaillant nous devons parler
français dans la classe
dans les cours de françaisisation à
Châteauguay près de la moitié des élèves
sont d'origine ukrainienne ceux qui sont
arrivés il y a près d'un an son
généralement rendus au niveau 4 du
programme de francisation du
gouvernement du Québec mais avec un
niveau 4 ils sont fonctionnels quand
même en général dans la vie donc ils
sont capables d'aller travailler aussi
et d'avoir une conversation avec
quelqu'un monsieur madame tout le monde
à l'épicerie ou de comprendre la
caissière Véronique Nantel leur enseigne
depuis leur arrivée de voir leur
progression du niveau 2 1 2 Alpha qui ne
parlait aucunement français de
maintenant les voir parler français
c'est super je me sens vraiment super
privilégiée mais ici comme ailleurs les
services d'accueil sont sous pression
est-ce qu'on a des élèves sur une
certaine liste d'attentes de la réponse
est oui ça que tout n'est le cours sont
utilisés il manque d'espace et
d'enseignants la francisation en
entreprise comporte aussi son lot de
défi parlez-en à cette directrice sans
ressources humaines tu sais autant pour
nous que pour eux je dirais présentement
ce qui arrive sont très les 12 travaux
d'Astérix Kathleen start ne sait plus
vers qui se tournait pour offrir des
cours de français pour ses employés
Irina Andriy jésus-crainiens qui
travaillent dans l'usine d'akuysystem de
câblage de Saint-Eustache depuis octobre
nous on pensait pouvoir le faire en
entreprise parce que service Québec
comme des subventions quand on les
demande on nous dirige ailleurs on
demande au Mifi le Mifi inscrit les gens
finalement les cours sont repoussés nous
avons vécu le même ping-pong
bureaucratique lorsque nous avons
demandé quelles sont les délais dans
l'offre de cours de français selon les
régions les ministères concernés ne nous
fournissent pas donner à ce sujet ou
encore répondre que l'offre actuelle
satisfait la demande nous devons
travailler avec un inter
prète mais ça fait maintenant presque
six mois qui Rina et Andreï sont arrivés
au Québec ils doivent communiquer à
l'aide d'une application
Erina était dévastée lorsqu'elle a
appris qu'elle devait attendre au mois
d'avril pour commencer ces cours de
français
j'ai pleuré et mon mari était bouleversé
car ils ont la volonté d'apprendre le
français pour s'intégrer et commencer
finalement leur nouvelle vie ici
Montréal
[Musique]